this video is sponsored by brilliant
so if you know about the history of the
Middle Ages you've probably heard of
guilds before the idea continues to be
in our culture in fantasy stories and
games but what were they really and what
was life like as a member of a medieval
Guild
[Music]
before we continue here's a quick word
from our sponsor and that sponsor is
brilliant
so while this channel has focused mainly
on history and social sciences it's
called the generalist papers for a
reason I love to learn about all sorts
of things from Linguistics to history
yes but also Math and Science I'll go
out on a limb here and say you are
probably like that too well good news
brilliant.org is the best way to learn
math and computer science interactively
brilliant has thousands of lessons to
help you learn math science and
technology there are lessons in
foundational math and calculus neural
networks and even artificial
intelligence so whether you are a
student or a seasoned professional
brilliant is for you to try everything
brilliant has to offer free for a full
30 days visit brilliant.org the
generalist papers or click the link in
the description the first 200 of you
will get 20 off brilliant's annual
premium subscription so don't wait click
the link below now and start take taking
your math and science skills to the next
level thanks again to brilliant and now
back to the video
so first off vocabulary guilds were
professional trade organizations that
popped up during the high Middle Ages
the earliest guilds formed in the 12th
century and they started as ways for
merchants to pool their money together
to afford protection from robbers at
home and Bandits on the road but they
quickly became more than that at their
height guilds acted as professional
associations political groups religious
brotherhoods and semi-secret societies
they were a central part of the
economics of medieval Europe
there were on the whole two types of
guilds trade slash Merchant guilds and
Craftsman's guilds these names give away
their meanings Merchant guilds were
groups of merchants people who sold
things most of the time all or most
merchants in a city would be in a single
generic Merchant's Guild but sometimes
you would find guilds for specific
traits like fishmongers sellers of fresh
fish or apothecaries sellers of Medicine
by the way Monger is an old word for
seller it comes from Middle English
manjer which in turn comes from the
Latin mango of course when I found this
out I got very excited but no
unfortunately it has nothing to do with
the fruit with craft guilds Things
become more varied and I think more
interesting they were organizations of
people who made things like goldsmiths
Masons Glovers Tanners Carpenters
Brewers Bakers Candlestick makers etc
etc guilds were tied to the cities in
which the guild members did their
business so there was no Countrywide
Weavers Guild instead you'd have a
different Weavers Guild in London
Newcastle Chester and so on
so guilds were groups of Traders and
Craftsmen founded in cities and towns
across Medieval Europe but what did they
really do well a lot actually their main
purpose was to oversee their specific
trade to ensure the goods made and sold
by their members were up to the right
quality and to promote their trade to
the citizens of their City
but they did more than that they oversaw
the training of new Craftsmen and set
educational requirements for them they
were also religious organizations often
having rules in their Charters about
church attendance and religious
observance they were philanthropic
giving some of their money to the poor
and caring for the widows of their
deceased Guild members they also
functioned politically since the members
of these guilds especially of the
merchant variety were some of the
wealthiest and most well-connected
citizens in their towns they invariably
became involved in the political life of
said towns because of this the laws and
ordinances of many medieval places were
very friendly to guilds and their
members
this leads us to some of the negatives
of Guild culture they almost by
definition were anti-competitive and
created monopolies over their trades if
you weren't aspiring Candle Maker for
instance you had no choice but to join
the local guild as starting an
independent Workshop was often actually
illegal they were also very exclusive
not just anyone could become a guild
member and those lucky enough to become
one held special privileges and Powers
other commoners did not
thank you
so what was it like being in a guild
well it started with training most
guilds especially craft guilds required
their members to be apprentices before
they could work in their trade training
usually started in a man's early teens
or so and could last as long as seven
years during this time an apprentice
would learn the basics of their craft
but they would also do chores and any
basic tasks too tedious for the master
but easy enough to trust with an
apprentice The Apprentice would not be
paid for his time but would be provided
with room and board as well as food they
were basically the unpaid interns of
their day
guilds also had requirements about who
could become an apprentice you almost
always had to be a man or boy in this
case and often you had to have a guild
member in your family or be sponsored by
a master who would agree to train you
who was usually a family friend
Anyway by the end of an apprenticeship
usually around a young man's late teens
or early 20s he became a journeyman a
journeyman was eligible for Guild
membership but couldn't open their own
Workshop they would instead work for
their Master for pay though they would
no longer get room and board for a
journeyman to become a master he would
need to produce a masterpiece in modern
parlance a masterpiece refers to an
exceptional piece of art one that will
be remembered for generations to come
like Beethoven's Fifth Symphony
Michelangelo's David or Van Gogh's
sunflowers but during this time a
masterpiece referred to a piece of work
that would prove to the other guild
members your skills as a Craftsman there
would be other requirements too like a
minimum age for instance it was also up
to the guild members who might not want
too many Masters in the city at one time
meaning even if you were qualified you
might not become a master right away
but once a journeyman became a master
they were able to open their own
workshop and take apprentices I should
mention that most Craftsmen never became
Masters as it was often easier to Simply
work for a master for salary instead of
opening your own business
as a full-fledged guild member you had
to follow the Guild's rules these rules
of course concerned the work you did as
we've already discussed but they
included other things too here's a
historical example these are some of the
rules of the Hatter's Guild of London
from 1347. one in the first place six of
the most lawful man of the Hatter's
trade shall be assigned to be wardens
they will rule and watch the trade two
no one shall make or sell any manner of
hats within the city if he is not free
and from the same city if anyone is
caught violating this rule he must give
up the hats that he made or offered for
sale
three no one shall be made Apprentice in
the Hatters trade for a term of less
than seven years anyone who receives an
apprentice or any other manner shall
lose his freedom until he buys it back
again
four some workmen in the trade have made
hats that are not high quality and this
deceives the common people and brings
great Scandal shame and loss to good
folks of the Hatters trade therefore no
workmen in the trade shall do any work
by night but only in clear daylight when
the wardens May openly inspect their
work anyone who does otherwise shall pay
a fine to the Chamber of Guild Hall for
the first and second offense and the
third time he shall lose his freedom
as you can see these rules set the
structure of the guild who can be part
of it how long they had to train and
rules for how to work I should mention
specifically the office of warden
wardens were in basically all guilds and
they were the most senior and respected
members
they had the responsibility of making
sure the other guild members were
following the rules
so those rules covered Professional
Standards here are a couple of Rules
from the Glovers of London from 1354
that show some other types of rules
1. every brother shall pay 16 Pence a
year by quarterly payment towards
providing two wax tapers to burn at the
high altar of the Chapel of Our Lady in
the new church beside London and also to
the poor of the fraternity who well and
truly have paid their quarterage as long
as they could two if any brother be
behind of the payment of his quarter
inch by a month after the end of any
quarter she shall pay 16 Pence that is
to say eight Pence to the work of the
church of Saint Paul of London and the
other ate pent to the box of the
fraternity also as often as any brother
be not obedient to the Summons of the
wardens or be not present in the heavens
that folk be dead and in offering at the
funeral of a brother and in attendance
at church
with the fraternity on the Feast of the
Annunciation and assumption and others
he shall pay 16 pence in like manner I
know that was a lot of legalese but
these rules give insight into the
payments Guild members made the fines
they had to pay and the religious rules
they had to follow specifically
attending Mass on certain feast days
held strong until the 16th century but
started declining after that and became
almost obsolete by the end of the 19th
century this was due to two main factors
one economic and one cultural
economically the guilds became outdated
once capitalism and economic system
based on the ideals of free trade
started taking off Adam Smith considered
the father of capitalism wrote against
guilds in his seminal work The Wealth of
Nations in it he criticized guilds for
stifling competition which in turn led
to higher than necessary prices and less
profit for individual merchants and
Craftsmen funnily enough Karl Marx the
father of Communism was equally critical
of guilds he targeted their inequality
and exclusivity which created an
underclass of workers who were not Guild
members the other reason many guilds
started losing favor was the Protestant
Reformation guilds were as we've seen
religious organizations and many
Protestants from Germany to England felt
that the guilds were too loyal to the
Catholic Church even if the guilds
purported to be Protestant because of
this the reputation of guilds in the
Protestant World began to dwindle but in
some ways guilds never went away many
modern professional organizations act in
similar ways to guilds with licensing
professional certification and the like
there are also some guilds that still
exist in the city of London there are
110 guilds called Livery companies that
still operate in the city and are an
integral part of the running of said
City the Freemasons a secret society
that spawns a lot of conspiracy theories
can trace its Origins to the medieval
Mason Guilds of Scotland primarily and
many modern unions can be thought of as
guilds as well
well I hope you enjoyed the video thank
you to my patrons for helping make this
work possible and too brilliant for
sponsoring if you'd like to support the
channel on patreon the link is in the
description and don't forget to like And
subscribe bye
[Music]